can i ask
uh dr don looney a quick question sure
um mr loney man you've helped me out so
much since you've joined
this team i've listened to i just enjoy
every day pretty much
my question is how do you deal with so i
come from a um
i'm an addiction household um
so uh i'm trying to figure out i'm gonna
do a lot of things as a kid
i have kids now myself and a situation
happened where i don't let
i've separated my family from my mom
because she is still
um in the addiction process and i don't
ever see it changing
it just kind of it hurts in an emotional
way because
growing up without grandparents i kind
of see my own kid going through it
and um and so i'm like a part of me
wants to be like hey you can come see
him
you know supervised but then part of him
is like man you're gonna break his heart
because you know my heart's been broken
before
right so um by her so i'm just trying to
see i mean
is it is it good just to be firm and
strong and
you know kind of um yeah you take that
pain on
you i mean you're wrestling with the
fantasy
of the the thanksgiving dinner with
grandma and granddad
and the kids running around and the
fireplace going and
that's not in the cards for you um or
it's not in the cards for you unless
your mom decides to
make some pretty radical life changes
which have happened they're hard
addiction's tough especially when you're
older but the reality is you got one job
and that's to protect your kids
that's to protect your kids in lieu of
the fantasy that you hold on to
and dude i hold on to fantasies like
that all the time i wish
you know my house would look like this
and my cars look like that we all have
fantasies that we walk around with
your number one job is to protect your
kids and so your instincts are right
your
your gut is right and man i just want to
applaud you
for making a hard right turn after the
childhood you endured
um and saying no more no more no more
and not for me in my house and so
man that's i i can't even tell you how
proud of you
i am jason you're you're a saint a
blessing and you're gonna raise
different kids man
you're a good man good for you changing
you are changing your family truth yeah
um i am i am because of you guys so
here's the thing
um it takes a lot of strength to be
gentle
and that includes even to your mom
and so but being gentle does not mean
that she has
enough access to them to bring damage
in any way i don't know if you have to
cut off 100
access or not that's something you might
talk through with your pastor or with
your coach or counselor
something like that depending on how
extreme and what she's dealing with and
so forth
we certainly cannot have the children
harmed in any way emotionally
um certainly not physically and so
but a hundred percent cut off uh uh you
know
may or may not be necessary that's up to
you guys but you're definitely going to
have to
limit it which you've already done and
um
uh the the thing is that this is not the
way it's supposed to be
it's supposed to be the other way with
the thanksgiving dinner and the
fireplace
and so there's not ever going to be
a moment in your life where you don't
wish
that it wasn't the way it's supposed to
be it's just not right
it's supposed to be the other way and if
it doesn't ever make you cry
if it doesn't ever make you feel bad at
times
then you're probably in trouble because
it should
it hurts and it's just because it's not
supposed to be this way
moms aren't supposed to be that way dads
aren't supposed to be that way
and um nobody wants to be addicted
right nobody wants to be over their head
for years and years and there's no
telling what his mom's story is growing
up and what she endured
and so i often will will
point people in the direction that
addiction is usually
it's a great way to compress and keep
stuff out that i don't want to deal with
i don't have the tools to deal with and
so i don't want to be in the business
about beating people up
who have addiction challenges i do want
to always encourage folks to go get the
help they need
right yeah and your kids and your
grandkids they need you in their lineage
absolutely they need you in their life
it could be and you don't want to
manipulate or something but it could be
that just
that this conversation gives her the
impotence to start working
right and that would be a really good
that'd be a wonderful outcome but it may
never turn out that way
and um you know having a baby doesn't
mean you're
a a a parent it just means you had sex
right
that's all it means i mean you have to
there's a line in the old
movie with steve martin parenthood i
think it was called the kid the teenage
kid is
getting ready to have a baby and they're
standing the thing talking and goes
you know you have to go get you have to
go take a test
to get a driver's license to drive a car
you don't have to do that to have a baby
no and you would think that you know i
mean driving a car versus having a baby
one is more important than the other you
know
right you don't have to you don't have
to pass a test matter of fact quite the
opposite right you might have failed the
test
or two or three right that's right you
flunked
you flunked on impulse or something here
but you know but
it's just uh what you're going through
sir is just heartbreaking and
because it's not the way it's supposed
to be
and so you your spirit is designed for
the way it's supposed to be
and when your spirit doesn't get that it
hurts
you just know that if you're listening
to this and you're struggling with
addiction
you want to go see your grandkids yeah
we want to spend more time
take the first step make a phone call go
get some help
go get some help there is healing on the
other side of addiction hard work it's
hard
hard hard but it's worth it oh it's
worth it
it's worth it your lineage is counting
on you